the Broadway's smash-hit Hamilton is
getting yet another accolade
members of the original cast of Hamilton
perform the song the Schuyler sisters at
the Kennedy Center Honors earlier this
month the musical has joined a
prestigious group of artists recently
celebrated for its contributions to
American culture the four co-creators
director Thomas Cale choreographer Andy
Blanken Buehler music director Alex
lacquer Moore and writer lyricist and
actor lin-manuel Miranda all received
the famous rainbow ribbon we spoke with
them in Washington about their historic
achievement for my Betsy loves me and is
acquainted with all the joys of fondness
what for lin-manuel Miranda a new
discovery of a love letter at the
Library of Congress can still thrill him
about Alexander Hamilton
[Music]
[Applause]
there are awards given in categories
then there is this award which is
basically being given to you all because
you have done something well I'll read
what it says trailblazing creators of a
transformative work that defies category
so they created a new category because
what you've the best way to win an award
for the first time ever a creative team
is walking away with a Kennedy Center
Honor but the four are no strangers to
acclaim choreographer Andy blank and
Bueller director Thomas Cale and musical
director Alex lakum or collaborated with
lin-manuel Miranda on in the heights
[Music]
Miranda Blanken Bueller and lack of more
each won a Tony Award for the show and
the twenty seven-year-old kale was
nominated for Best Director
[Music]
all-4-one tony's for hamilton it's not a
singular effort the Broadway musical is
based on Minds coming together
problem-solving creating being inspired
[Music]
where is this collaboration taking place
in its various different times for the
first few years it was just happening in
my head on vacations and it was like the
ghost of Hamilton it would be like hey
write write a song for King George which
got written on my honeymoon
you'll be big so you see and tommy was
like we should start setting deadlines
because if you're gonna average a song a
year this is gonna take us very long
time our first deadline was a concert we
did at Lincoln Center's Jazz at Lincoln
Center
I remember seeing Andy in the audience
going like
[Music]
and me like oh Andy's gonna end up
choreographed this
and so then Alex where's the story go
from there
it usually starts when Lin emails the
demo of the site and then I'm like okay
how do we get a band to play this how to
get singers to harmonize in chords to
support what the story is what to
support what the melody is
[Applause]
[Music]
describe how you would explain the way
Washington was I mean like
right-hand-man is a great example
because my right-hand man was always
supposed to be like Washington stepping
out of an oil painting
he's so grand he's a god to us and the
bullets never hit him I've literally
never heard you describe it that way
before which is amazing
[Music]
it was exactly pulling Washington down
off the oil painting it was let's not
meet Washington standing Crossing the
Delaware somehow not falling off this
tiny canoe let's meet him being like I
don't have enough money I don't have
enough troops and we're losing how do
you not basically get on each other's
nerves oh well I think that we respond
to each other's energy in a way that's
really positive Tommy has a way of
setting a room where the best idea in
the room wins and you know if I bring in
a song and I see Andy's already left to
his feet and alex is already playing
with variations I'm like okay we're
pretty far along the course if I bring
in a song and it's quiet I go okay I
swing into this
[Music]
you know my feeling about it is we all
understand instinctively that the stakes
can be high and the temperature of the
room can be low and that you can make
excellent things with harmony
[Music]
this can be proof that it's possible to
make something of high quality that
didn't result from acrimony or you know
or raising your voice if nothing else
that's one of the things that I hope it
becomes part of the legacy of the show I
remember thinking to myself like I did
not want to ruin this because everything
that Lynne has given us is so amazing
we brought you together because we
wanted to tell you something you ruined
it it was there ever a moment where you
thought gee rap about having States
debts assumed by the federal government
that's not gonna fly this plant would
have the government of food States dead
now place your bets as to who that
benefit I remember the first time Lynne
brought the demo to me and I heard it my
first reaction was I couldn't tell it
was trying to be tongue-in-cheek I was
so taken because it was so different I
didn't know what to expect if you talked
you're gonna get shot so it was until a
year later until I heard my shot and I
heard that chant I am NOT throwing away
my shot
and I started to see oh my god Lin is
dead serious about this and it really
started to fill me with something and
never pictured the founding fathers with
this kind of energy with this kind of
passion and drive for Miranda Hamilton's
life and his words seemed tailor-made
for the stage what can I do better than
withdraw from the scene every day proves
to me more and more that this American
world was not made for me and he feels
lucky that he got to tell the story I
couldn't believe it hadn't been told in
this form it just it seemed like someone
else would have had this idea already
I'm really grateful that I found the
right collaborators to help get it out
of my head and getting out of the void
oh that was so good I love how Annie
says it is not a singular effort and I
can remember it's not just the music of
Hamilton it was the court I can't
remember the last time I had seen a
musical on Broadway where there weren't
elaborate sets where the main attraction
were the people who were performing and
singing alone I mean it's like nothing I
had ever seen before they deserve this
recognition and in talking to them you
can see them all working and playing off
each other and you could see it in the
piece while we're it's happening right
in front of us I mean they are this
organism that operates as for yeah you
can make excellent things with harmony
yeah we'd like to think that Lynne
Manuel's wife has forgiven him for
thinking of songs during their honey
yeah and our collaboration and Emer
lists did a great job producing that and
have you Chapman editing it so you are
the product of great collaborations as
well and you can watch the tribute to
Hamilton and all of the artists honored
by the Kennedy Center on Wednesday
December 26th it airs at 8:00 7:00
central right here on CBS